What do you think overall
was the hardest part?
The divorce.
It was the hardest,
you know, time of my life at least. Um,
it was just as there's a dark,
dark time.
So first off,
can you just say your name and Jimmy Chai?
40 years old.
Taletha Chai,
41,
don't believe him.
Uh,
we were in college working for the,
uh,
the college newspaper and he came running
in and he had long hair at the time.
It looked like an Asian Jesus.
I don't know.
There was just something about him that
I liked and I hadn't even really heard
him talk much.
Just something about his presence.
I like thought up something to ask him
and we just started talking from there.
Okay.
Uh,
she borrowed money from me.
There was a time when I'm at night where
we were just bored and just laying out
the paper.
And so there was a,
a calendar of quotes on the date of the
table and if you want to say like these
inspirational things. And so I
would tell her, hey, as a joke,
anytime someone walks to the door,
I'm just going to sneak in a quote to
the person and just see if they catch it
and she would die laughing. Do you
know any way? Lessen the jokes.
I think I just want a little bit.
So that's when I knew so many, uh,
so many what you could
actually,
I don't know if she wants
me to tell her this story,
but I'm going to say it
anyway. Can you hear me? No.
One time she, um, she,
she was driving home and she had
to go to the bathroom to go pee.
And so instead of pulling over because
she was rushing home and I don't remember
why she was rushing home,
but she had a coffee cup in her thing.
And so she peed in a coffee cup. She's
gonna hate me for this, by the way.
I know she didn't hit me,
but it's okay.
We just, without saying anything,
know what the other person,
where they're going to go and what
they're going to say are almost like
finishing each other's
sentences or something. Yeah.
She's a very, like probably the
most pure hearted person I know.
Like we have two beautiful daughters
right now and I wouldn't want anybody else
to be the mother of my children.
Looking back,
it's like you forget the little moments,
you know?
Like I was telling him the story about
how we used to have the calendar,
remember never enough to close when
people walk in and you'd be dying that,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Things that other people would think
would just be so wrong with us as we're
like, no, that's that to be happening.
I knew I wanted to give me the mother
of my children because of who you are.
Like I knew you'd be an amazing mother.
It was just like a heads down delete.
Just going to be an amazing mom.
And I wanted this woman to
be the mother of my children
early.
Yeah.
It wasn't what I would call a typical
dating courtship where it leads up to a
proposal. It was very up and down.
It was an emotional rollercoaster.
Well,
we were still just so disconnected at
the time and so our communication really
wasn't there. Like, I
don't know, we just sort of
let it pass by
that couple unit. Um, just
seems like 200 people, right?
Yeah.
I got to see the one thing that we found
common ground and always was Seinfeld
when Seinfeld was huge and the one
thing that would always bring us back
together dating us, it's
like Seinfeld, okay,
we're finding those flashlights
all is good with the world.
I was on the living room floor and
I was playing with our two children.
It was just like late at night.
And I remember realizing all of a sudden
that I was very lonely and that um,
I felt like a single mom
and how
they were three and five,
they wouldn't remember a whole lot.
I just knew that the healthier route
would be to do this now and we weren't
where people that would not
want to live our life like that.
It was a lot of this is how
you're supposed to be. Like,
why won't you be like this?
No, to be honest with you, looking back,
it was just more of a frustration from
my side and I blamed her for a lot of
stuff.
So I played a lot of victim and I felt
very stifled and looking back it was more
me than it was her. I knew we shouldn't
have been married to begin with,
so it wasn't like a,
I knew the marriage was over,
like we fought on our wedding
day the whole time. It was crazy.
We were so attached to the way it looked
like and on top of that I had pressure
from my family.
It wasn't fair to her and like she
had no shot to be honest with you,
with me now looking back, oh my
gosh, I self sabotage the whole way
most of my life. It was just easier
to just keep everything inside,
deal with it myself and
just react to things.
And so I regret not telling you in a,
in a really productive
way what I needed most,
which was what a partnership
to walk next to each other.
It was just awkward bill
for a very long time.
Eventually just the friendship
started to come back. We,
we've, we talk about the same things.
We find the same things interesting. Um,
he is one of the longest relationships
that I've had in my life besides that
we'd had in our lives besides
our parents and our siblings.
We just want to be the best
people we could possibly be.
Our marriage was filled with just holding
our faults to each other and you know,
holding, holding what was right or wrong
about each other against each other.
And now we're really obsessed with that.
There is no right and there is no
wrong and we're really obsessed with,
I'm not giving up. We're really
obsessed with that. This is a process.
I mean,
to be honest with you,
if you look at our relationship now,
people would think we're married because
we get along so well and I don't know
too many couples that get along like us.
Whether you're married or not married.
It's difficult for my relationships
that I have now with girlfriends because
they don't understand this.
I can't.
And so that's why I don't have,
that's why I'm single.
Okay.
That
I value this relationship that has been
such a big part of who I am because we
have children.
I know that we're going to have a
relationship for a really long time.
And
I guess just sometimes I imagine the
end of my life being able to look at you
and without saying a word no,
that we shared a pretty amazing journey.
I, I wish I was kinder to you.
I wish I was more understanding.
I wish was more authentic
and wish I was there more.
She had no idea
what I regretted the most,
was not being open enough and are
really telling you what was on my mind.
For me it was I wish over kinder to you.
Okay.
Honest,
authentic,
loving and, and another thing that
I didn't say was like committed.
I was one foot in one foot out a lot
of ways. What was it fair to you?
Yeah,
we see the world the same way.
We just don't live in
the world the same way
we've been talked about us as
a unit in a very long time.
It's always about the kids.
So it's pretty interesting.
Yeah. To us. This is really
the only unit that we know.
I talked a little bit about just how
friendship was always just an underlying
thing. Yeah. So
yeah, we were always really
good friends to each other.
Okay. Nice to meet you.
Nice to meet you. Yeah.
Okay.